bonjour julien à la une dont
qu'évidemment les analyses du discours
des manuels macro hier soir première
prise de parole après les législatives
et vous nous dites que la presse n'est
pas tendre avec le président tient donc
une envoyez-lui quelles que soient les
sensibilités politiques de la presse le
constat général est amer regarder cette
une de libération qui parle d' un
président totalement dépassé incapable
de surmonter la crise politique après
son échec pour les législatives emmanuel
macron a prouvé qu'il n'avait pas du
tout compris le message des français
écrit l'éditorial il est je cite dans le
déni de la situation surtout après qu'il
a rejeté hier soir la responsabilité
d'un éventuel blocage des institutions
sur les groupes politiques l'opposition
c'est justement ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire le dit le figaro se défausser sur
ses opposants sur ses opposants pardon
leur dit il est à la clarté et à la
responsabilité écrit le journal il faut
aussi changer le ton change et le
gouvernement change et le cas bref il
faut tout changer à commencer par le
style de présidence qui ne peut plus
être verticale une partie de la presse
voient dans ce chapitre inédit de la
cinquième république une nouvelle façon
de voir de faire de la politique en
france oui cela s'appelle par l'homme le
parlementarisme nous dit l'opinion
journal plutôt libéral plutôt pro macron
la priorité absolue doit être d'éviter
la paralysie du pays écrit le quotidien
pour cela il faudrait que les députés
macro nist et le gouvernement soit prêt
a plus de discussion a plus de
négociations
dans les faits cela peut ressembler à
faire un rubik's cube le parallèle est
bien trouvé l'un des derniers alors
c'est pas ce désir là ce sera un autre
que je montrerai pour la prochaine fois
le parallèle est bien trouvé l'un des
derniers records du monde pour résoudre
ce casse-tête célèbre été fait par un
français c'était moins de six secondes
il fera sûrement un peu plus de temps
aux députés pour trouver un consensus
sur les futurs loin voilà pour la presse
française qu'en dit la presse étrangère
mais bien de manière générale elle se
montre très durs à l'égard d' emmanuel
macron je vous donne un seul exemple le
tag et de sai tom entre un président
français dont le piédestal est en train
de s'effriter c'est là le symbole d'une
verticalité du pouvoir qui d'après le
journal allemand a montré que le
président français l'orgueil du
président français était devenu sa
propre perte avec cette réélection
emmanuel macron penser que la l'inédit
les législatives ne serait qu'une
formalité sauf qu'il avait oublié que
les français écrit ce journal avait voté
contre marine le pen et non pour lui il
n'y a pas que la france qu'il connaît
une crise politique qui sera elle aussi
on lit dans nos journaux la grande
coalition au pouvoir depuis un an s'est
donc effondré comme un château de cartes
et de nouvelles élections devraient se
tenir d'ici l'automne prochain
effectivement une crise politique de
plus pour israël avec le départ cette
fois ci du premier ministre naftali
bennett sur fond de désaccord avec sa
grande coalition et ce ne sera pas cet
homme qui parviendra à relever le pays
d'après israël à y sommes hier et la pid
anciens journalistes l'un des hommes
forts de cette coalition sortante qui va
devenir donc premier ministre jusqu'aux
prochaines élections qui auront lieu
normalement à l'automne prochain sauf
que d'après le quotidien même si lui se
place plutôt sur le centre gauche de
l'échiquier politique est bien avec une
coalition fortement marqué à droite et
surtout à l'extrême droite est bien le
pays risque d'être encore une fois
ingouvernable comme cela avait été le
cas avec naftali bennett et dans ce
contexte damien est bien qu'ils se
trouvent en embuscade un visage bien
connu de la politique israélienne on le
voit ici dans ce dessein d' allahou sa
datcha ac charlotte pardon l'ancien
premier ministre benyamin nétanyahou
dont l'appétit dévorant pour le pouvoir
n'est un secret pour personne depuis un
an comme chef de l'opposition nous dit
arrête netanyahu n'a cessé de cogner sur
la coalition gouvernementale pour mieux
je cite la faire tomber et d'après le
quotidien les prochaines élections
seront le théâtre d'un match semblant
entre la pid et netanyahu c'est fort
probable en prend la direction de
l'afghanistan au lendemain du séisme qui
a causé la mort d'au moins un millier de
personnes avec cet appel à la une du
journal suisse le temps sur les
problèmes d'acheminement de l'aide
humanitaire dans ce pays enclavé d'asie
centrale l'appel de l'afghanistan
sera-t-il entendu s'interroge le
quotidien le gardien lui rappelle que
s'ils payaient autant démunie face à
tête cette catastrophe je rappelle plus
d'un millier de morts plus de 1600
blessés et d'instants raison de l'
isolement international de l'afghanistan
survenus après le retour des talibans au
pouvoir l'été dernier le quotidien écrit
que les dirigeants afghans ont
d'ailleurs demandé à la communauté
internationale de passer outre les
sanctions et donc de faciliter
l'acheminement de l'aide humanitaire
sauf que depuis le début de l'année il
est différent en appel pour aider le
pays face notamment à la sécheresse est
aussi l effondrement l'économie sont
presque resté je cite sans réponse avant
de nous quitter julien on va on va
parler d'un des quinquagénaires les plus
célèbres de la planète voyage du roule
uniquement vidal et je vais montrer ses
parties à la une va là à la une de
l'équipe les 50 ans aujourd'hui tout
pile de zinedine zidane le célèbre
joueur de l'équipe de foot de france et
aussi du real madrid 16 pages
d'entretiens exclusifs avec l'équipe
l'occasion pour lui de revenir ce que ça
qu'à deux joueurs sur ses plus grandes
victoires ses plus grands échecs aussi
l'occasion aussi d'évoquer sa jeune
garde entraîneur déjà marqué par trois
ligues des champions remportées avec le
real de madrid notamment et puis aussi
la réponse que se posent tous les
réponses à la question que se posent
tous les supporters parisiens est-ce
qu'il sera le prochain entraîneur du
paris saint germain
malheureusement a priori non zidane ne
cache pas sa priorité de devenir le
prochain sélectionneur de l'équipe de
france peut être que ce sera après la
coupe du monde au qatar mais dit-il pas
qu'ils sont fermé la porte à paris un
jour peut-être conclut-il
mystérieusement merci beaucoup je dis on
suivra donc l'avenir de zinedine zidane